he's not getting convicted in the senate
we all know this democrats know this the
republicans
know this that puts to the side the
question of whether he should be
convicted
in my opinion the answer is no the
reason being that the standard that is
laid out in the impeachment article
is not a neutral standard that can be
applied across the aisle if you're going
to say
that he is responsible for incitement as
we're going to get to in just a moment
you're also going to have to say that
reckless rhetoric by a variety of
politicians
which results in action that was
unforeseeable
is going to be attributable to them and
therefore they also can be kicked out of
the chamber that's going to hit a lot of
members of congress a lot of senators
and a lot of future and past presidents
by the way so in any case the arguments
were laid out yesterday
trump's lawyers did not do a good job by
virtually all accounts trump's lawyers
were pretty bad
uh there was a fellow named caster bill
caster who was one of trump's lawyers
and he was not particularly good jamie
raskin
was given wide plaudits for his
presentation of the
of the pro-trial argument and jamie
raskin
uh is of course a representative from
maryland he said if we don't impeach
trump that would create a january
exception to the constitution the case
he's making constitutionally
is that basically what you're saying is
if you can't impeach him
after he's left office then let's say
the president does something super duper
duper duper corrupt
on january 15th well i mean now you're
basically making the case the president
can do whatever he wants so long as it
is close enough to him leaving office
now that does leave aside a couple of of
major issues one
is that that kind of is true
already for second term president right
if you are if you are a second term
president
then you being convicted after having
been impeached
after leaving office makes no difference
you are legally barred by law from
running for presidents of the united
states again
so if barack obama were to be impeached
and convicted now
there would be no actual penalty that
attaches because he's not actually
legally allowed to run for president
again so for second-term presidents it
already exists
this sort of january exception that
raskin is talking about
but the the broader argument is not a
terrible one which is that you don't
actually want to create a feeling
that the the president of the united
states can do whatever he wants in the
final month without having to worry
about any consequence whatsoever
from congress what it does suggest that
the proper measure here would have been
censure which is something that i had
suggested months ago kevin mccarthy had
suggested it months ago that democrats
turned it down flat because of course
they wish to force republicans to the
mat the idea here is they want
republicans to vote
for trump's impeachment and conviction
and nothing else they don't want the
opportunity for republicans to
distance themselves from trump's actions
without also voting for impeachment here
was jamie raskin making the case
yesterday
this would create a brand new
january exception to the constitution
of the united states of america
a january exception
and everyone can see immediately why
this is so dangerous
it's an invitation to the president to
take his best
shot at anything he may want to do
on his way out the door including using
violent means to lock that door
to hang on to the oval office at all
costs okay so a couple of things
okay so now he's making a case that he
has not yet made right that's the case
that they're going to try and make today
which is that trump tried to violently
overthrow the united states government
which is not true
okay but let's talk for a second about
this so-called
january exception okay the reality is
that presidents do bad crap on the way
out all the time
bill clinton pardoned a bunch of his
political allies on the way out of
office this is very very common
barack obama did a bunch of terrible
political stuff on his way out of office
up to and including his administration
monitoring the incoming trump
administration
and sticking law enforcement on them
without any sort of cause and so it
turns out the presidents
fairly often do this sort of thing where
on the way out the door they do a bunch
of stuff that they knew they couldn't
get away with if there were still two
years left in their terms that's not a
particularly strong argument
however bruce castor is the name of
trump's attorney he did not make a
particularly compelling case yesterday
he was trying to make the case that the
impeachment was unconstitutional
even trump himself was apparently very
angry with bruce castor's performance
yesterday virtually every republican
senator was like i don't know where you
picked this guy
up i don't know if he was like a
personal injury attorney in dubuque and
he sort of grabbed him
off the line and decided to throw him up
there an impeachment trial but
he did not receive plot it's not a lot
of great reviews for bruce castor
yesterday
if we go down the road that my
very worthy adversary here mr raskin
asks you to go down the floodgates will
open the political pendulum will
shift one day
this chamber and the chamber across the
way
will change one day
and partisan impeachments will become
commonplace okay so he's not wrong about
that part
right the idea that there's gonna be
partisan impeachments all the way down
he is
he's not wrong about that once you open
the door to repeatedly impeaching a guy
over and over and over
that does set a precedent caster said we
this was the most awkward moment
he he sort of said jamie raskin is doing
an unbelievably good job here
and um and we have responses to that
stuff but we'll get to that later it's
like okay well
you know you didn't need to do that that
was that was not useful here's bruce
castro yesterday
i'll be quite frank with you we changed
what we were going to do on account that
we thought that the house manager's
presentation
was well done and i wanted you to know
that we have responses to those things
we have counter arguments to everything
that they raised
and you will hear them later on in the
case from mr van der veen
and from myself so um not great not
great bob
meanwhile trump's other attorney got him
david shane he played tape of democrats
calling for impeachment since the very
first days and this is a better case
right he's saying
that when it comes to the
constitutionality of impeaching trump
that is one thing when it comes to the
politics of impeaching trump but it's
pretty obvious that democrats believe
that trump's illegitimate they've been
after him since
day one uh it was amazing to watch the
media the clown themselves by the way
just a quick side note it's an orthodox
jew the media absolutely many in the
media become themselves yesterday
because shane is an orthodox jew
and there was one point where he took a
swig of water and he took a swig of
water he put his hand on his head
and a bunch of people in the media were
like well that's funny he put his hand
on his head it was a leak
essie cup from cnn does he have a leak
up there no that's not how that works
just so folks know i wear a yamaha well
the reason that jews wear yamaha
orthodox jews wear yamaka is because
you're supposed to cover your head when
you make a blessing you're supposed to
make a blessing
every time you have food or drink he was
not wearing a yamaka
so this happens fairly frequently if
you're not wearing a yamaka you've
forgotten to put one on or you're not
wearing one
and you want to make a blessing you put
your hand over your head in lieu of
yamaka that's what was going on
yesterday in any case
side point but our culturally sensitive
media ever ever culturally sensitive
uh they went nuts over that and then
later had to walk that back in any case
shane played tape of democrats calling
for impeachment since the very first
days and this of course is true
who i may well be voting to impeach
donald trump has already done a number
of things
which legitimately raised the question
of impeachment i don't respect this
president
and i will fight every day
until he is impeached that is grounds to
start impeachment proceedings those are
grounds to start impeachment those are
grounds to start impeachment proceedings
yes i think that's grounds to start
impeachment proceeding i rise today mr
speaker
to call for the impeachment
of the president of the united states of
america
so um yes i mean that happens to be
right from trump's attorney's team which
is
okay you guys keep saying that he did
something impeachable but you've been
saying he's been doing impeachable stuff
since literally the day he arrived on
the scene
so take everything that you say with a
grain of salt that said was the case
particularly compelling on a
constitutional level
not particularly bill cassidy the
senator from louisiana he voted he
switched his vote
since last week he said listen trump's
legal team did a really crappy job on
this particular issue now that doesn't
mean cassidy's voting for impeachment
it means that he's voting in favor of
the idea that it is constitutional to
impeach
frankly i tend to agree that it is
constitutional to impeach a president
after he has left office that doesn't
mean i think that it should be done in
this case but as far as the actual legal
constitutionality of the thing
i think there's a fairly strong case
fairly strong argument uh that it is
constitutional to do that sort of thing
after somebody has left office so
and that if that is the standard that we
are now going to apply then i look
forward to applying it
into the future here is here's bill
cassidy making the case yesterday
it was disorganized random had nothing
they talked about many things but they
didn't talk about the issue at hand
and so if i if you if i'm an impartial
juror
and i'm trying to make a decision based
upon
the facts as presented on this issue
then the house managers did a much
better job
the issue at hand is is it
constitutional to impeach
a president who's left office and the
house managers
made a compelling cogent case
and the president's team did not
alrighty so bottom line though is that
it passes but it doesn't pass with like
flying colors the six senators who voted
in favor of the constitutionality were
the five from last week
plus cassidy that is not gonna be nearly
enough to get democrats across the
finish line on actually convicting trump
in the senate facts don't care about
your feelings and it's a fact that the
ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content